so jet lagged from australia you are why
no one recreates it keeping up with the
kardashians scene like a jonas brother
it's
amazing and that's just what joe jonas
did on sunday with the help of his wife
sophie turner i'm so excited about it
the 32 year old singer teams up with the
game of thrones star to recreate this
iconic scene from the hit reality show
where kim kardashian simply cannot be
bothered by her sister chloe
so jet lagged from australia you are why
because i just came back from australia
so jet lagged from australia you are why
because i just came back from australia
sophie as kim
okay someone hand that girl the oscar
because that was an award-winning
performance it's great it's wonderful
you are why
and we're not the only ones loving it
it's such a beautiful thing
coco gave it her stamp of approval
sliding into the comments to give the
funny moment three crying laughing
emojis
genuinely i cannot believe it but joe
bros fans know this isn't the first time
they've blessed the internet with a
kardashian reenactment
don't
be rude are you kidding me yeah they
went there it's really special so where
is there exactly good question the
kardashian circle like 2008
don't be [ __ ]
rude let's rewind shall we to season two
of keeping up with the kardashians you
know the episode where kim gets a
bentley and her sisters courtney and
chloe mock her for being a brat and all
hell breaks loose
don't be [ __ ]
rude are you kidding me i swear to god
okay now fast forward to 2020
when joe gave us the gift of recreating
the scene with some help from his
brothers nick and kevin
don't be
rude are you kidding me i swear to god
don't be what are you throwing the thing
on me i'll [ __ ] hurt you don't do
that oh my god
naturally joe captioned the clip don't
be rude okay but wait my favorite part
though is when kevin crosses the screen
dead and you know who else was dead over
it kim kardashian herself i'm really
honored and humbled the 41 year old kkw
beauty founder hit up the comments
writing omg
she also shared the video on twitter
writing alongside it i love you guys
and chloe she weighed in on instagram
commenting on joe's post
nailed it it's crazy and a few months
later joe was back at it this time
channeling court and her youngest sister
kylie jenner cause i'm gonna get wasted
i just finished a cold cup of 42 and i'm
about to go for my second one courtney
what are you on
i don't know what's going on so i'm just
appreciating my bread
is it just me or is it impossible to
pick a favorite jonas kardashian moment
so i'll leave you with this a montage of
their greatest hits cause i'm gonna get
wasted
don't be [ __ ]
rude are you kidding me
so jet lagged from australia you are why
because it just came back from australia
[Music]